[Applause]
i am so excited to talk to you about
many things um
i want to first start off with you
released your first holiday album i
couldn't believe it was your first
and your son is on it will you please
tell me about what
making that album was like and what the
experience was and thank you for putting
it out into the world
well it was always a bucket list um
thing that i have always wanted to do
there's just so much about you know
touring and making albums and timing
stuff that it's sometimes hard to
just do everything you want to do all at
once so you have to you have to figure
it out
um i knew at the end of 2019
that you know this was kind of that was
the next step i wanted to take and
started working on the christmas album
and it was just such a joy
uh for me especially throughout 2020 to
be able to work on such positive music
and getting to sing christmas you can't
be upset you know in
in the time that you're just singing
christmas songs so it was it was such a
nice um stress
reliever for me to be able to go into
the studio and
and sing these songs and um little
drummer boy
is one of my my favorite christmas songs
ever
and as i was recording it uh i could
just hear my son's
little perfect five-year-old voice um
singing these words because that's just
his personality he's a giver
he wants to make things for you and give
things to you
and he likes to write songs he'll just
here's the song i made up um
so i asked him if he might want to come
in and sing with me and he was super
excited and did such a great job
now when you hear his voice because i
don't know
if singing is hereditary if it is
there's no one in my family that's a
singer
uh we're all actors um how do you know
like or just was it like this was just
fun and you wanted to do it
well it was just fun and i wanted to do
it but i i also
you know you can kind of tell when when
someone has pitch
um he can sing along with me and he you
can tell what song he's singing if he's
just singing on his own because he's
singing
the correct notes i mean he is he's
almost six but
he is just you know a little guy so i
don't i don't know if he'll
have that or have that passion at all um
we're we're supportive of whatever he
wants to do but he definitely has has
pitched
so i figured him coming in and singing
um
we could we could make it uh to where
you know use the best parts of
of whatever he did and uh and and make
it good but honestly most of it was from
one one take which is impressive is that
now one of those memories that just
lives on yes i mean i i told everybody i
was like i don't know how cooperative
he's gonna be i don't know
if he's gonna once and be like i don't
wanna do this anymore
um but if nothing else i have this
moment
i have this day he got to come to work
with me and see what i do
and um it was such a magical experience
in the studio
but then having that moment ingrained
forever um in a musical form
his little voice he already pronounces
his rums
like for just from that point to this
point he doesn't say
anymore he says parampa pom-pom and it's
like that was such a fleeting moment
it's not there anymore and and i have
that
forever it's so true like my kids if
they come visit me at work i don't know
what you know version of them i'm
getting that day
and sometimes they'll come on and just
be into it and cute and charming and
want to participate
some days you know they're not in that
mood
and it's it's exciting when
they're in your world you can enjoy it
things are flowing
it's like these are these moments i
cherish so much
can't get him back that's for sure that
just sounds just like my favorite line
in planes trains and automobiles he's
missing his daughter's play
and john candy looks and goes yeah those
moments don't come around again
okay i have to ask you about
organization
i hear you're a fan of
organization and it's
just it wasn't my forte growing up i was
like pig pen
and i lost everything and i was just
bohemian and whimsical and now i'm
really trying to
be a different person what are your tips
for organizing what is carrie
underwood's tips
for organizing i mean i feel like it's
important to
to focus on one thing i feel like if i
if i walk into my kitchen my kitchen is
overwhelming
if i just walk into my pantry and like
that is what i'm taking charge of that
is what i'm organizing
um i feel like that is is doable it is
one
one space work on one space one drawer
one little area don't just go in because
then you feel like you haven't done
anything
you you could work all day and if you're
just willy-nilly putting stuff away
you feel like you haven't really gotten
accomplished you don't see it in front
of you
if you work on one drawer one pantry one
thing then
that's doable and then sometimes i feel
like taking things out
like taking all of it out and putting it
back in the way it should go
is is helpful instead of just moving
things around
um and and while you're doing that you
can throw things
away um got it you got to be brutal let
it go
if you're not going to use it if it
doesn't serve your purpose if you're not
going to eat it
if you're not gonna like whatever you
have worn it in
you know a year like just let it go
my therapist baruch because i have a
time management thing i'm trying to
conquer he was like you need to be
ruthless
yeah on yourself and that's a word
that's really stuck
with me and haunted me so much lighter
afterwards when you get rid of when you
purge um and then
all the things that you need are right
in front of you
you can breathe it just feels better
there's someone who said this saying
your head is as messy as your room is
and it just was the light bulb and
i heard you even like make your bed
every morning
yeah i mean that's if i if i don't have
time i don't have time but
when i walk by my room if i'm there in
my house and i walk by my room and my
bed is in shambles i'm like
it just irks me every time i walk by it
so at some point i have to stop and i
have to
to make it um and then each time i walk
by i feel good
well it's funny because i read that you
like to make your bed and when
the person said your head is as messy as
your room is a starting place for me
was the bed and it became symbolic of
like i start the day this way
that intention might carry me through
other areas
well and it's it's the kind of thing
that it's like okay does this take me
that long to do
no like just do it and get it over with
and then get on with your life and
that's how i look at you know
working out and taking care of myself
too
just get it done get up go go to the gym
then you've done it it's over
you feel better you're doing something
good for yourself and you think about
just making your bed but it makes you
feel better and then you've done it you
check it off the list and you move on
and get on to more important things and
you have that foundation of
i've already done something today
you